bu mahkum öğretmenden bir Almanca dersi
daha bir git hal hatır sormak Bilge test
diye Nasılsın İyi gecesi giyinen
nasılsınız lan ki eski etme Kut Teşekkür
ederim iyiyim sanki Eski etme yazar bu
Teşekkürler çok iyiyim sanki Eski etme
yaptırayım ha Teşekkürler harikayım
zoupa bunda pa mükemmelim ses gitmemiş
bu iyi değilim eski etmemiş kız robot
çok iyi değilim eski etmesin Ay kötüyüm
abone ol
A1C testi nasılsın sanki Eski ekmegi
Teşekkür ederim iyiyim bize test iğne
nasılsınız Can ki eski ekmek Grup
Teşekkür ederim iyiyim iki Siz İran
burada erkek kardeşiniz olsun kanki eski
ettiğim Grup Teşekkürler o iyi biliyor
tesbih ilaç Western Kız kardeşiniz nasıl
sanki eskiyi götür Teşekkürler o iyi
video test iremkent Çocuğunuz nasıl
sanki Eski ettiğini bulduk Teşekkürler
oluyor
bu monet'nin ikamet etmekle devam edelim
bu enerjiyi
bu hosto
bu ihvanin Ankara ihvani Ulus itfaiye
İzmir ihvanin Maltepe bu Nez ise büyük
saygı duyduğumuz duymadığımız bir kişi
sorarken Nerede oturuyorsunuz şeklinde
sorarız Baba ustu sen nerede oturuyorsun
hep bunlar da cevaplar Ben Ankara'da
oturuyorum ben Ulus'ta oturuyorum ben
İzmir'de oturuyorum ben muhabbeti de
oturuyorum
bu mor woolston Ankara Ankara'da mı
oturuyorsun ya ilk bana inan Kara Evet
Ankara'da oturuyorum
şu boğaz turu ilk önce oturuyorsun Naif
13 tutkal hayır sukrat de oturuyorum
bu Conan Ağustos bir yerden gelmek
konusu az Adana Adana'da mı geliyorsun
Konya'da Usta Adana Adana'da mı
geliyorsunuz ya ilk 16 Adana Adana Evet
Adana'dan geliyorum Ne ilk 16 Samsun
Hayır Samsun'dan geliyorum
ve komsu Adana Adana Adana geliyorsun ya
İsko Mouse Adana Evet Adana'dan
geliyorum Kur'an Usta ağız Adana
Adana'da mı geliyorsun Nike ilk 16
Samsun Hayır Samsun'dan geliyorum
ve kendimizi tanıtırken forname Adımızı
familienname soyadımızı Alper yaşınızı
haymat Land memleketimizi bu nohut
oturduğumuz yerin söyleriz
ve kendinizi ruh forma göre tanıtım
yorum kısmına yazın Almanca dersleri
videolarımı beğeniyorsanız beğen tuşuna
basmayı unutmayın kanalıma abone olun
beni takip edin